El mandato de los españoles y españolas,
y es lo que voy a hacer,
lo que he hecho durante estos últimos 5 años,
políticas de progreso, de avances sociales
también, lógicamente de convivencia.
Creo que nadie
en España puede discutir que hoy
la situación en Cataluña está infinitamente mejor
que en el año 2 017.
Y ahí están los resultados electorales
y finalmente, en el Marco de la Constitución española
y cuando se den a conocer los acuerdos,
no tengan ustedes ninguna duda,
serán públicos,
transparentes
y por tanto validados por el poder legislativo.
E incluso si quieren
ser recurridos ante el tribunal constitucional
por parte de la oposición,
también tribunal constitucional.
Plena normalidad democrática.
Yo creo que esto es lo importante.
La democracia española
está trabajando
por Dar eh cauce y materializar el mandato
que emanó de las urnas el pasado 23 de Julio